The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? It's been a long
time and it's been a long time since
I've been with this uh this specimen.
This chump.
This specimen of an individual over
here. This fine gentleman. Ali. Oh, you
talking about Zan. Ali
Da. the champion of the young da in in
in London. So, how long was your hand
there? I didn't see it.
Um, but there's another champion in
town. We've been waiting for this moment
all this time. This guy This guy's a one
of the major signs has been established
of the day I'm dressing. To be honest,
something minor actually. Yeah. This one
is a minor guy. He's a beauty man by
every stretch of you. Oh, let's watch
it. You know, there's some Let's There's
a man who has claimed to be Al Mahi and
some people actually have taken him a
little bit seriously. Not that many
people have, but um he came out with a
beanie hat. He came out with a beanie
hat. The actors in this podium here,
they've been paid.
Let's take a look at some of it. Let's
see. Miracle of Elijah. am who called
down fire from the sky to show the
people where the truth lies and where
falsehood is buried and say truth has
come and falsehood has perished. Surely
falsehood is ever bound to perish. God
is with us my believing brothers and
sisters. He has made his choice clear
and he has honored us with this great
sign. He conquered the usurpers and the
appointees of the devil. For the title
of pope is not an ordinary one. The
title of pope is claimed by those who
say they are the vice gerant and
successor of Jesus Christ Alisam. The
pope who sat in the Vatican claimed to
be the spokesperson for Jesus, the
representative of Jesus, the heir of
Jesus, the successor of Jesus, and the
divinely appointed voice of Jesus. But
all of this is a lie. Jesusam appointed
his successor in his lifetime, and none
has the right to appoint but him. He
appointed Simon Peter when he said, "And
I tell you that you are Peter, and on
this rock I will build my church, and
the gates of Hades will not overcome it.
I will give you the keys of the kingdom
of heaven. Whatever you bind on earth
will be bound in heaven and whatever you
loose on earth will be loosed in heaven.
So Jesusam named the first of his
successors and he named the last as well
the comforter. He said therefore I'm
sending you prophets and sages and
teachers. Some of them you will kill and
crucify others you will fogg in your
synagogues and pursue from town to town.
He also said because of this God in his
wisdom said I will send them prophets
and apostles some of whom they will kill
and others they will persecute. Clearly
Jesusam spoke of prophets who would come
after him and he named the chief among
them. Nevertheless, I tell you the
truth.
It is expedient, Jesus said, for you
that I go away. For if I go not away,
the comforter will not come unto you.
But if I depart, I will send him unto
you. And there has never been a man in
history who claimed to be that comforter
except the best of all prophets, the
master of mankind, Muhammad Sam.
He became the inheritor of the
messengers, the successor to Jesus, and
the father of mankind, the true pope.
And as every prophet did before him,
David naming Solomon, Moses naming
Joshua, Jesus naming Simon Peter, so too
did Muhammad sallallahu alaihi name his
successors. On his deathbed, he dictated
to Alibabam that after him would come 12
imams who would be to him as the
disciples were to Jesus except that they
would follow in succession. And okay,
what' you get so far? There there's like
a Shia theme. There's a Shia theme. Um
there's there's people in you know the
way that they
do it's like Iranian way of it's like
almost a far accent actually. You notice
this image in the back this green it's
like this Ali Yeah. Yeah. Because you
know that in in in Shiaism you can
actually depict when they can draw. I
heard there was a French artist that
drew that whole you know that picture
they have. We we had it in our house. Is
that meant to be him? That's him. But
usually with the image of Ali Radulan, I
heard it was drawn by a French artist.
Yeah, it might be because it's like
European kind of. But the main things is
that it brings a bigger question. How do
we actually recognize
this guy? It's not that hard really cuz
he
rejects rejects. He's probably not even
a Muslim. He's a kaf actually. Forget
about we can't have a kafi. We can't
know like the one who went Zach Zach he
was he was a Muslim the one remember Zak
he came out and he said I'm yeah maybe
this no but at least for him you can say
he's a Muslim yeah you can you can say
there with him he's call he's a he
rejects Quran reject sorry not the salah
everything when he's finished
um And there's a lot of women following
him. Really? I don't think they're
following him. I mean, there's there's
I think so because it looks like it's
kind of cosplay like it's he's a poor
actor. He's not a good one. He's on my
level. And and not and not only that,
not not only that, the one thing that
I'll show you as well. Yeah. It's that
he's um Yeah. Let me just show you. He
was part of some kind of No, no, no, no,
not not that. Not he was part of some
cult as well. Some madness sexual. Yeah,
but not even not even that one. There's
there's another one. He's a successor to
this engineer. One second pope. But
Islam doesn't have a but the prophet
clearly states the mahi is from my
progeny from the children of Fatima.
Abdullah follows Ahmed al- Hassan an
Iraqi civil engineer with no proven
lineage to okay that's his that's his so
he's an engineer. Oh okay. So
no, but the way he was speaking even you
can tell he was not um he was not an
Arab by maybe he has Arab parents or
something like that but he wasn't
pronouncing the the words properly and
you know he was like saying it all wrong
and for someone who claiming to be the
Mahi come on come on at least pronounce
Quran properly. What do you think? What
do you think causes these kind of
individual? I like sometimes I look at
at the motivation. Well, he's got his
fundraiser there, hasn't he? I mean, I'm
here. Here I take it personal. He's a
hustler. No, I think I take it personal.
Is that what you're going to do next?
I'm I'm a good salam. Matt said you're
going to say I'm a
I'm a fun. You're going to see a few
women following you as well. Yeah. Yeah.
He's raised $9,245.
That's not even that much. I mean, Salam
Salam gets more than that in a day,
isn't it? In a couple of hours.
So the thing is when he got to his place
his
fundraiser meth as a fundraiser I mean
it's it's getting a bit pathetic here.
This is where he stepped into my field.
Oh my god. I got a little bit upset
there for a second. But yeah, he's a
fundraiser. I mean if you think about it
guys I do fundraising for the salah
charity the prayer matter how to pray
salah. Maybe I can see the guy. Well he
won't do anything with it cuz he
doesn'tcept. He doesn't even accept the
salah. So he's going to look at it maybe
throw it somewhere use it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not going to send him now.
I'll change my mind. Yeah. But uh no, I
mean it's you know this the bigger thing
about this thing is that we need to be
aware of the signs of the day of
judgment and we're going to do a series
in sapiens on the signs of the day of
judgment and we're going to intellectual
I'm going to personally do it myself.
I'm already starting to do the bit of
the research the minor signs the
predictions and then the major signs. If
someone is very secure in those aspects
then yeah it's like you know the person
is not going to be falling for this kind
of thing. someone who doesn't fit almost
any of the like actually fits all the
the opposite criterion of ali this that
would the question won't even come to
their mind as whether they're they're
charlatans or not charlatans. This guy's
he's a he's a poor actor. He's like an
below average actor. Do you know what
I'm trying to say? So like uh but the
the bigger thing is for us to be
acquainted of the the signs of the day
of judgment.
his beanie. He's got a beanie, brother.
Coming and this and that. And oh, and
I'm the pope, so he's meant to be the
pope. Why has he got very serious face,
bro? I can't take him seriously, bro.
Come on, man. Just get out. I would I
wonder what goes with their mind, bro.
Like, when they do this stuff, like,
what actually goes through their mind,
you know? He's He's got a very slappable
face. Let's see how much of a medi he is
when he gets slapped his face. I I
guarantee you this kind of man, I can
see in his face, he would not respond.
Yeah. You give him one slap in his face,
going boom, like that in his face, the
beanie falls off. He's not he's not he's
not going to respond. You can see he's a
coward and a liar. Yeah. You can subhan
Allah and you can just tell by the
faces. Yeah. Subhan Allah. I mean yeah
that's it. He just we just find these
kind of things funny. And Mai himself
the genuine Mai he would not he would
not accept the authority. Yeah. He'll
run from the authority but then he'll
have then he'll end up having authority.
He doesn't even seem to control the
fundraising. He wants he wants
authority. That's the the thing that
disqualifies him. Oh yes. Yeah. And well
the first thing is he's a kafir. But the
second the second the second thing about
it is he he's chasing authority and it's
the opposite of what he shouldn't be
chasing anything. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That's chasing. We call this false
man to Islam. Yeah. Yeah. You know to to
just take the beanie off and we'll teach
him I'll teach him how to pray salah.
Yeah. Salam is doing an excellent job
teaching people how to pray salah and
stuff like that. Yeah. We've got a
couple of different languages now as
well. whichever one he speaks for cuz he
can't speak Arabic. We've got Italian,
German, French, Spanish, Portugu, even
Albanian. So any if he speaks any of
those languages, the M will help him
greatly. Anyways, with that we'll
conclude. Hey you, are you wasting your
time on social media? Again, your
brothers and sisters in Islam net from
Norway are establishing a masid, a da
center. Establishing a masid to convey
the message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.